the time of the deposit versus the time
of the compound sometimes is so
important they will specify it right
when we revert to this situation they
don't need to anymore they can revert
back to the normal situation that math
doesn't go weird i wonder if any of
you've worked it out by now why that is
it has to do with when you're doing that
previously question and it's happening
in lots of 12 right you won't get lots
of 12 if what normally happens maybe
interest first and deposits later you'll
get instead of 12 24 36 you'll get 11
2335 the bat sees the numbers are very
frustrating so anyway well give this a
go oh I do want to make a caution even
without me having made that slight
adjustment I looked around in a few
books and I saw a lot of problems very
simple ones i want you to all look back
at your working now look at each of your
numbers i can always guarantee it if you
had a problem it came early on i think
most people are good at building step by
step where the problems happen is when
you make an assumption at how those
steps of shape if that makes sense pay
particular attention to where the
deposit comes up and what the interest
is that's what I've been seeing a lot of
people missing I didn't want to I was I
was contemplating going out to
individuals saying doing my thing and
saying how sure are you about that but I
think you've worked out that's my way of
saying hey you're wrong but I'm not
going to tell you how so I just sort of
blanket saying some of you have got
issues with the series that you fault
okay so let me show you how I would do
it now but ever beat me about all right
now we've already decided that there are
smart ways to do this and let's not ways
to do it so one of the two alternatives
what it's your turn I could say the
amount after the is what I could go with
the bud
okay or alternatively I could go with me
here right now I won't make you I won't
take another phone because you've done
the clothes today but which do you rake
you would make more sense their last
time we are we went with month okay and
then we saw what happened and we're like
it's getting a little boring and then we
started skipping towards years okay but
here we change sticks sir is it going to
be different let's roll with it and
let's see what happens okay hey what
okay so I've got my $1,000 again after a
month how many repayment term i made a
nun okay but I happy very generous to me
though I've done jag all they've
actually added some interest to you
that's nice okay how much is the
question now don't forget this interest
rate is per annum right so if i want to
change it to an interest rate per month
which is how much they're adding every
bug it's not twelve percent anymore I'd
be love you about 12 essentially every
month very happy ability it's one
percent it's twelve percent on 12
because that's how many compounding
periods i have in that one year so
therefore i'm adding 1 percent per month
so this should be one point 01 okay
great no problem what happens next one
how many payments in my bed and some
none but they have added a sign of
deposit they've added a water interest
I'm kind of okay great do I need to do
another one what happens the next book I
still haven't put any money in I wonder
so do you hold the answer for why I
wouldn't do that by the way but they
have added more interesting right
can I skip something watch nice gift do
11 okay what happens after a little well
I have my 1000 and it's had how many
watts of interest well 11 because there
have been 11 months so what happened
next one I make a deposit right so I've
got this right now do I make the deposit
or do they do interest passwords right
and then I make my deposit wouldn't I
say probably okay now can you see why by
the way see they're always going to set
it up I'm gonna try to set up so the
numbers are going to work for you if I
had done the other around this would be
11 then it'll be 23 and 35 we don't
under the car do multiples all right
great there's a year can we go forward
do we do we want to do the next one so
do you think we can skip a few I think
you guys are pretty bright that's good
let's go to 24 okay so what happens in
that space of time well they add
interest lots of times in fact they add
interest 12 times which lends you on 24
then this deposit event it's got its own
interest hanging out there which is
great the same whoops whether the same
more of interest and then I make another
payment okay can we do 36
I've got my original notes hey it's got
how many lots of interest that many then
you get these deposits happening this
one has been in there for two years by
now right this one has been in there 41
years four months and then you've got
your most recent one ok so again I can
start to make a series here this guy's
hanging off the front like a bit of a
loner right what should I factorize up
12 you again to make the growth of the g
people obvious i'm going to write in
reverse order so i've got one life young
I've got one point 01 to the 12 you and
then I've got one point I one to the 24
there ok can I generalize give you do it
what I'm going to have let's sit this is
going to be 1.01 how many lots of
interest is a half well it matches up 36
36 right so that's going to be in then
I've got 1,200 ok have a look I'm going
to have these first terms but what will
the last term be this is 24 is 36 this
one was 12 this was 24 it's n minus 12
isn't it ok now the previous question I
think this is a kind of where we stopped
which is a bit norden because we really
should have done this from and said this
is a GP this is a GP we're now what are
its defining features what's the first
term hey is one no problems that's the
rain what's the cyber brain what's the
ratio where every time I go up in this
laws it's one point 0 1 and 12 on right
one point 01 to the 12 ok now careful
how many terms up I just shouldn't say
em because there's ends already in here
ok how many terms up
let me touch with you this is a 56 I saw
one two three times I go back 24vac how
many total a bit in the suit I didn't
factorize to take it obvious but there's
one to turn down or 12 is it and on 12
terms which is why you can see when n is
not in fact a multiple sorry but it's
not a multiple of 12 you've got problems
here its GPS and progressive because it
only progresses every 12 months because
that's when I make a deposit okay that's
kind of weird right this means that this
breaks down when it is not a multiple of
12 my formula doesn't work because I
don't actually add parts of like if I
had if this was like dying or something
like that I'd get a bit extra but i
don't i don't really write so therefore
this works this is true but i think it's
an awkward way to write let me just
finish it off use the sum of a GP to
simplify that a little bit once 1,200 ok
the formula is I'm going to use our into
the minus 10 so a times e to the ok look
what happens there that's all I guess
race the power n that's it right number
of terms a bitter would say so it's
actually that times that oh you see
what's happening still tied 1-1 all /
sorry all divided by r minus 1
so this up here is actually just that
you see what that corresponds to that's
how much interest gets added every time
now you suggested to me a month I think
we can actually go with you grant
because the same thing is happening
right before we were making payments but
nothing was happening to the payments
right now interest is getting added on
but no deposits of being made so I still
have to wait for 36 and 48 and 60 so I
might as well go to every year right
what's going to happen well the numbers
going to change in the river right how
many watts of interest will my original
amount 3624 a whole year is elapsed
right so every year I get 12 compounding
food so that should be 12 and yeah okay
now what's goin on here I'm going to do
the series from scratch okay so this is
this is quite separate what we're doing
okay
what's going to happen up here or
Cindy's numbers right these numbers will
be different that 1200 is still sane
right but how much of them do i add how
much would them to an end it's going to
be one then there's going to be careful
everything is divided by 12 is good so
this is nice because what do that that's
yep there are we too and this will be so
I should have dogs or the last one we
see how this was n minus 12 but
everything is divided by 12 right so
this is going to be a 1 point 0 1 to the
power of
hmm
now I actually gonna make a suggestion I
reckon we should have actually built it
from a year from the beginning this is
kind of a general rule you can see now
that you've gone through the pain of
gaudiya from scratch see this is
confusion we are happening right now
this is exactly why we start from one
the reason you're confused is because we
didn't start from one so you're like I
don't know what we're up to because I
don't know where I'm coming in the story
of how this whole being developed okay
it's smarter to start by you whichever
is the less frequent of the event it
doesn't matter if its deposits or
repayment or compounding or whatever
that's your basic hit at a time right
whatever these are it doesn't really
matter all that much I'd like you to
build this again from strategy but this
time to work in terms of years okay
you're like oh why did you do this to me
I had a teacher you ate and uh he would
make us do methods like this and you'd
be like okay go through get nat turner
at the end and then you tell us the
smart way I'm he'd be like okay remember
all that pain you just went through you
can save this up all that pain by just
we have right the first time okay here's
my question to you we know it's going to
end on something what will it be build
it from scratch until me now to make you
feel a little bit better I will give you
the answer for why in reality this is
what I do this is what my mortgage does
it compounds daily they can banks okay
but i only make payments monthly here's
why I do it I work how often do I get
money for working annually I get a 45
minutes then I get it for knighted so
what i can do is i can make a budget on
a fortnightly and monthly basis I know
that seems weird but you can actually
get its purchase some food for you okay
and I can know this month this is how
much will come in this is how much is
going to go out because I budget this
ready but if it's every day even if it I
actually get some long-term benefits for
a reduced amount of interest it throws
bunch of all out
just because people don't hit the third
pay me daily I can't make payments daily
does that make sense I owe you get paid
daily show it doesn't make sense so
that's why in reality this happens all
the time